with the return of centre-left
government to norway after eight years
of conservative rule one question looms
large what does it mean for the energy
sector that made this country fabulously
rich
now we shall celebrate sleep a bit and
then be ready for action we will change
norway and the world
it was an election dominated by the
climate crisis and the growing
realization that fossil fuel exports
must make way for renewable energy
that's a profound shift for a small
country operating western europe's
biggest oil and gas industry it accounts
for 14 of gross domestic product and 40
of exports providing norway with a 1.4
trillion dollar sovereign wealth fund
for me personally the main issues for
this election is the environment so what
i expect from the new government is to
focus even more on the climate issues we
are facing today we need a change
in a serious one we need a government
that takes
the environment
with greater concern
tricky coalition talks lie ahead first
with potential left-wing partners
wanting faster moves towards a green
economy and labour opting for a more
gradual transition the new government
will also pledge itself to tackling
rising inequality a cause that already
ranks high among norway's neighbors the
election means all five nordic countries
are now in left-wing hands for the first
time in 62 years jonah hull al jazeera